[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه اخبار الظهيره
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
تركيا والعراق
تجمعات الاحتجاجيه ايرانيه في اوروبا
دائما للمتظاهرين والحرس الثوري ينتشروا
في مدن كرديه
مقتل مئات المسلحين البولنديين في معارك
خياف وكيف تتاهب لعاصفه ثلجيه
في كاس العالم المانيا تسعى لتجنب الاقصاء
المبكر والمنتخب المغربي يتحدى بلجيكا
اذا المشاهدين تركيا وصلت ضربتها الجويه
في شمال سوريا طبعا هذه المره مستهدفه
مطار منك العسكري وايضا قرى بريف حلف حلب
الشمالي عذرا بحسب المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان خلال خمسه ايام من الغارات الجويه
التركيه وذلك في المناطق الكرديه بشمال
سوريا قتل واصيب حوالي
225 شخصا من العسكريين وايضا من المدنيين
المرصد ذكر ان سلاح الجو التركي يوجهوا
ضربات جويه مكثفه عبر الطيران الحربي
وايضا طبعا الطائرات المسيره من الاراضي
قامت ايضا المدفعيه التركيه باطلاق
القذائف بشكل مكثف وايضا نتحدث عن 125 شخص
فقط وبصوره عامه خلال الايام الخمسه من
القصف التركي اما الليله الماضيه فقط
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التركيه تحيد 22 مسلحا
من حزب العمال الكردستاني شمالي سوريا
وايضا العراق الوزاره قالت في بيان نشراته
على موقع التواصل الاجتماعي انه تم تحيد
عشره مسلحين شماليه العراق واثني عشر
شماليه سوريا مؤكده انها ستستمر ملاحقه من
وصفتهم بالارهابيين واينما كانوا طبعا
وبينما يستمر هذا القصف التركي قال المكتب
الاعلامي لرئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني قال ان رئيس الوزراء بحث في
بغداد مع رئيس الاتحاد الوطني الكردستاني
با في الطالباني ملف الامن وايضا تامين
الحدود العراقيه جدير بالذكر ان المجلس
الوزري للامن الوطني العراقي كان قد اعلن
الاربعاء الماضي وضع خطه لاعاده نشر قوات
على طول الحدود مع ايران وايضا مع تركيا
دعونا نتابع
اقامه حزام امني من الغرب الى الشرق على
طول الحدود الجنوبيه لتركيا لابقاء الحدود
امنه هدف انقره التي تشل سلسله غارات جويه
على شمال شرق سوريا ومواقع لمقاتلين اكراد
يقول الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
المنطقه الامنه ستسمل بحكم الامر الواقع
مدينه كوباني او عين العرب التي انزعتها
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في العام 2015 من
تنظيم داعش بدعم من الولايات المتحده
الامر الذي ردت عليه قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في حديثا للعربيه مؤكده ان
المنطقه الامنه هي امنه فقط لتنظيم داعش
بدعم تركي تركيه هي لم تكن موثوقه بالنسبه
لتحالف الدولي منذ عام 2014 بسبب علاقتها
الواضحه مع تنظيم داعش الارهابيه نحن
شاهدنا والعالم مشاهده
البوابات
وجرابلس واعزاز مفتوحه بين داعش دوله
تركيا
التي تنوي انقر القيام بها اكدتها اسد
مشدده على انها بكامل جهوزيتها لصديق اي
هجوم بري والدفاع عن المنطقه وسكانها
واشنطن جددت معارضتها الشديده لسن تركيا
عمليه
تلوح بها منذ ايام شمالي سوريا وطالبت
انقره بوقتها لانها تهدد امن الجنود
الامريكيين الموجودين في مواقع لقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه في المقابل اعربت روسيا
عن املها بعدول تركيا عن تنفيذ عملياتها
العسكريه البريه واعتبرت ان لا احد يريد
تصيد التوتر
جمعه اخر التطورات الميدانيه تفضل
جمعه هل تسمعني
طيب يبدو ان هناك مشكله في الصوت سنحاول
العوده الى مراسل يسمعني الان في ما يبدو
جمعه هل تسمعني
طيب السؤال كان يتعلق باخر التطورات
الميدانيه المعلومات المتوفره لديك
يعني اتجاه العمليات يعني يتحول من شرق
الفرات الان الى غرب الفرات يعني من مناطق
نفوز الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى
مناطق نفوز اا روسيا والمليشيات الايرانيه
والنظام السوري عندما نتحدث عن مطار من
العسكري هذا المطار يتقاسم السيطره فيه
اضافه الى الروس ميليشات ايرانيه والفرقه
الرابعه تابعه لماهر الاسد اضافه الى
تواجد يعني محدود بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
تحديدا في المطار ومحيط المطار المطار
الذي يتعرض الى ضربات عسكريه كبيره ربما
كان هناك صاروخين سقطاع على اطراف المطار
بحيث كانت تركيا تريد ان ترسل رسائل الى
الروس والى النظام وايضا الى ايران بانها
عازمه على الدخول الى مدينه رفعت لكن
الوضع على الارض الوضع في الرفعه منطقه
الشهباء وضع عسكري بوجود عده قوى تتقاسم
السلطه والسيطره في هذه المناطق وبالتالي
اذا كانت روسيا قد اعطت كما نفهم يعني
الضوء اخضر مبدئيا يعني
لتركيز عمليه عسكريه محدوده فان
الايرانيين لم يوافقوا على دخول تركيا
موقفهم واضح من الدخول الى مناطق الرفعت
والشهباء خاص
بالكامل الموقف الامريكي وتحيه تلك
المنطقه الان من خلال هذه الاستهدافات
ماذا يعني همم اكراد قالوا بتصريحات بما
معناه انه اذا كان سيكون هناك عمليه لن
تكون سهله على الاتراك اذا على ماذا
يعاونون
ااا الموقف الامريكي اعراب لكن الاكراد
هنا يقولون هل هذا الرفض كافي للحيلوله
دون وقوع عمليه عسكريه بريه الاجابه في
الشارع لا هذا الموقف غير كافي لكن عندما
نتحدث عن غرب الفرات غرب الفرات لا تتواجد
فيه قوات التحالف ولا يتواجد فيه
الامريكان القرار هو روسي وايضا ايراني
وايضا قرار هذا النظام السوري وبالتالي
هناك اربع قوى تتقاسم السيطره على الارض
تحتاج تركيا الى الحصول على الضوء اخضر
هذه يعني التحشدات التي سمعنا عنها على
الطعام في ولايات كلها وايضا ضربات هي
عباره عن اختبار لمواقف هذه الدول سواء
بحيث تكون يعني ترفض هذه العمليه او همم
بس سؤال ليتعلق بالتعويل الاقراض على من
يعني اذا الجانب الامريكي يرفض ولكن بخجل
الروس مش معروف الموقف الحقيقي في ما يبدو
وبالمقابل حتى ولو وبذلك عندك الايرانيين
همم
والنظام ايضا السوري كما ذكرت وبالتالي
على ماذا يعول الاكراد بالنهايه يعني نحن
نسمح من الاكراد بانهم يعاورون على قوتهم
العسكريه هذه القوى التي خسرت في ما سبب
عفرين وايضا فاثرت الابيض لكن الاكراد هنا
وخاصه قصده يقولون بان اساليب الدفاع
ستكون مختلفه ونقاط الحرب ستكون الاوسع
همم مما تحاول تركيا ان تحدده في مدينه
معين له وهم يتحدثون عن همم
حرب على طول الحدود نتحدث عن 612 كلم حدود
مشتركه من دينه حتى من بين الاتراك همم
الاكراد هم طبعا يعولون على الموقفين
الامريكي والروسي همم لكن من الواضح ان
هذين الموقفين مع اسرار تركيا علشان عمليه
بريئه غير كافيه لحمايه الاخرى
ما بين الاكراد والنظام السوري في هذه
المعركه ما حدثت
اذا كنا نتحدث عن غرب الفرات يعني في
مدينه الرفعت من المؤكد اذا كان النظام
السوري يعني لم يعطي اي موافقات لتركيا
تهيئه الارضيه لاي تقارب سياسي بين
اردوغان وبشار الاسد بالتاكيد سنرى يعني
قصد والميليشيات الايرانيه والنظام في
خندق المواجهه خاصه عندما يتعلق الامر
بترفعت ووجود يعني ارنبيه شيعيه في لبول
والزهراء الملاصقتين ل همم
سنجدهم في خندق ال- ال- المواجهه في حال
لم يكن هناك موافقه من النظام لتركيا
بالدخول الى الرفاعات او من الروس على
الاقل في دخول رفعت لكن هنا ماذا ستتحصل
عليه روسيا مقابل رفعت هل سيكون جزء من
جبل الزاويه الواقعه تحت همم يعني همم
سيطره المعارضه السوريه
على كل من القامشلي وراس العربيه جمعه
كانت شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
مشاهدينا ننتقل الان الى الداخل الايراني
المظاهرات تتواصل في عدد من الجامعات طبعا
تحديدا بممارسات النظام القمعيه وايضا
احتجاجا على وفاه الشابه مهسا امينه في
جامعه امير للتكنولوجيا بالعاصمه طهران
منظمه الطلاب احتجاجا على اعتقال السلطات
لعدد من زملائهم في جامعه العلامه طبائي
بالعاصمه ايضا زينه طلاب في كليه الاداب
زينوا كلياتهم برموز برتقاليه طبعا
بمناسبه اليوم العالمي للقضاء على العنف
ضد المراه هذه بعض الصور طبعا من داخل
الجامعه الصور
ايضا من الجنوب العاصمه طهران ادرما
المحتجون النار بصوره قاسم سليماني تحديدا
في مدينه
طبعا النهارده على هذه الاحتجاجات جدد
قائد الحرس الثوري الايراني حسين سلامي
جدده هجومه ضدها هؤلاء المحتجين ووصف
الاحتجاجات بانها مدبره وصل سلام
انتقاداته للاحتجاجات قال انها حرب كبيره
ضد النظام الايراني تشنها دول الغربيه وقد
تم توثيق مقتل اكثر من 400 محتاج واعتقال
حوالي 14000 حتى الان طبعا كل ذلك بحسب
تقارير الامم المتحده الانتشار الامني
المكثف مشاهد فيديو اظهرت انتشار قوات
الحرس الثوري في مدينه بركان الكرديه
وطبعا مدن اخرى في كردستان تمهيدا لهجوم
بري على الاحزاب الكرديه المعارضه شمال
العراق دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
ايه ده المشاهدين تعزيزات امنيه تحدثنا عن
اعتقالات عن قتل وايضا هناك قرارات بالعزل
عزلت السلطات الايرانيه الاستاذ الجامعي
وايضا رئيس مركز تعليم اللغه الفارسيه
لغير الناطقين بها في جامعه بشتاشي بطهران
محمد راغب طبعا عزلته لمشاركه في التجمعات
الطلابيه راغب اعلن انه تم ايضا قطعه
راتبه الشهريه
وايضا طبعا هذا بالنسبه للداخل وما يحدث
في الداخل ايراني اما في الخارج فقد وصل
مئات الايرانيين الى جانب مواطني دول اخرى
دعم الاحتجاجات ضد النظام الايراني قاموا
بتنظيم تجمعات احتجاجيه وذلك في عدد من
الدول نبدا من فرنسا حيث نظم عدد من
الايرانيين المقيمين في باريس نظموا
تجمعات احتجاجيه دعما للانتفاضه الشعبيه
ضد النظام الايراني ننتقل الان مشاهدينا
همم ايضا الى برلين حيث نظم عدد من
الايرانيين تجمعات بمناسبه اليوم العالمي
للقضاء على العنف ضد المراه طبعا واشعل
الايرانيون بهذه الاحتجاجات شموع لتخليد
ذكرى من قتلوا خلال التظاهرات الشعبيه ضد
النظام في ايران
ايضا حلقه
العشرات من النشطات رؤوسهم او قصوا شعرهم
في ميدان بكدله بي لندن دعما لحقوق المراه
في ايران حيث هزت الاحتجاجات البلاد في
عقاب مقتل محساء امينه كما ذكرنا من بين
المحتاجين هذه الفنانه الفنانه فيكتوريا
التي حلقت راسها بالكامل وسطه وفاه
الجماهير التي نادت بعبارات ثلاثيه المراه
الحريه وايضا الحياه
[موسيقى]
الفلوس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
على كل المزيد معنا من برلين ميسره باكور
مدير المركز العربي الاوروبي للدراسات من
هناك اهلا بك سيد ميسره اسمحلي ان ابدا ان
كان لديكم اي معلومات من الداخل الايراني
وقراءتكم للقرارات الايرانيه يعني بدانا
نتحدث اولا في المواجهه
ثم تحدثنا عن اعتقالات عن قتل استخدام
النار الحي والان ايضا عزم عزل يطال بعض
الهيئات التدريسيه هذه القرارات كيف
تقيموننا
المشاهدين الحقيقه ما تفعله ايران هو
النسخه طبق الاصل عن الذي فعلته في سوريا
حصار تجويع فصل الموظفين ثم ااه القبض على
المتظاهرين قتلهم في المعتقلات ثم اتهام
جهات الى الدوليه همم الارهاب ودعم
الارهابيين والقبض على مئات الاشخاص من
العصابات المموله خارجين وكل هذه الاشياء
السخيفه حقيقه انا هو التصريحات همم
الصادر عن في الايام القليله الماضيه شعر
بانها جنونيه بان اا ومن خلالها تقراين ما
بين السطور بان الضغط اصبح كبير على
السلطات الحاكمه في ايران من خلال هذه
التصريحات والعداء همم لانتقاد الغرب
وانتقاد امريكا والحديث عن محاوله ااه ضرب
ايران في العمق اللبناني والعمق السوري
واليمني وكل هذه الامور الامور هذا الدليل
على ان الضغط كبير وكبير جدا ولاحظ ان هذه
التصريحات جاءت بعد ايام اعضاء المنتخب
الايراني في المباراه الاولى في كاس
العالم برفض همم
ترديد السلام الوطني الايراني ومن ثم
تصريحات اللاعب الايراني المهم الذي همم
قال بان يزيد معه حق ضد هذه العصابات التي
تحكم همم
الكثير من العلاقات هنا مع ايرانيين
وتتحدث معهم ويرسلوا لنا لانه نحن عندنا
صفحات اخباريه هنا في المدن الالمانيه نشر
همم المظاهرات والمصور لهم بعض المقاطع
ونشرها في الصف احنا بالتالي همم
لاحظت ايضا ان معظم ال- المظاهرات تتركز
في المناطق ذات الاقليات الكرديه
البلوجستان والعرب ويشكلون الضغط يعني همم
كاني انظر الى خارطه سوريا في عام 2011
2012 نفس التصرفات ونفس المنطقه للاسف
محكومه ههه
تحدث عن تصريحات الايرانيه الرسميه هناك
بعض من يقول انه ربما هناك سيكون نوع من
الصوت المعتدل اذا ما صح التعبير يخرج
الان في ظل هذه الضغوطات هل فعلا يمكن ان
يخرج من قلب هذا النظام صوت معتدل او يمكن
ان يخلق اذا ما صح التعبير
انا لا اعتقد ذلك ولكن ان حدث اعتقد انها
مناوره سياسيه من النظام لان هذه النظامات
الانظمه الشموليه القائمه على
الارتقراطيه الدينيه يعني ولي الفقيه
يعتبر نفسه ممثل للرب في الارض بالتالي
ممنوع حد يناقشه وهو اعلم رئيس الجمهوريه
بالتالي
سياخذ من صلاحيات الالهيه وهذا مرفوض
والحرس الثوره يقف الى جانب خميني
بالقتل العمليه يعني بداوا بقتل الناس
وترهيب الناس وتهديدهم بالسحر
وحكم بالاعدامات التاليه
هذه الانظمه التي تعتقد بانها تستمد
سلطتها من الله مستعده لتقديم اي تنازلات
وخاصه اننا لا نجد الضغوطات حقيقيه من
المجتمع الدول خاصه اوروبا التي محكوم
الان بين ظرفين الظرف الاقتصادي الصعب
وموضوع ال همم البترول والغاز والحرب
الاوكرانيه التي تهدد اوروبا بالتالي همم
الحكومه في ايران تستغلها زي المساحه وهذا
الهامش الرفيع لتقوم بقمع
المواقف الغربيه من برلين ميسره بكور مدير
المركز العربي الاوروبي للدراسات منبرلين
شكرا جزيلا لك
في اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل معارك
عنيفه والدفاع الروسي يعلن تحديدا مئات
المقاتلين القولندي
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الظهيره يشهد
محور دوناتس تركيا في الشرق الاوكراني
معارك عنيفه بعد صد القوات الروسيه هجمات
اوكرانيا مراسل العربيه ذكر ان القوات
الاوكرانيه بدات تشون هجمات من محورين
في اطراف مقاطعه لوغانس بينما القوات
الروسيه تقول انها تصدت لهذه الهجمات من
جهتها اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه مقتله وتحيد
مئات المسلحين البولنديين في معركه على كل
من هناك الى داخل مركز قياده القوات
الروسيه والشيشانيه في مدخل مدينه خرسون
الكاميرا العربيه تنقل صور هذه الصور طبعا
حصريه من داخل المركز الذي قصفه الجيش
الاوكراني في الهجوم المضاد الذي قاده
لاستعاده المدينه
والحدث في مركز قياده القوات الشيشانيه في
مدينه خرسون هذا كان مركز القياده للقوات
الثانيه والقوات الروسيه
في مدخل مدينه خرسون ايضا هناك يوجد
المستشفى الذي كان يتم فيه علاج الجرحى من
مناطق العمليات من مناطق تمركز القوات في
القرى والمناطق القريبه من هنا
كان مركز قياده المحتلين الروس اكثر من
نصف القوه كانت من قوات قدير الشيشانيه
يقولون انه من سحبوا طوعيه هل سقطت عليهم
نيازك من السماء لقد اجبرناهم على
الانسحاب كما ترى تم تدمير مخزن الاسلحه
الصواريخ الروسيه كانت في هذا المبنى الذي
استولوا عليه من احدى الشركات كانوا
يستولون على المباني التي يرغبون فيها ولا
يفرقون بين المباني الخاصه والمباني
العامه هنا كانوا ينقلون جرحاهم من مناطق
العمليه
يمكنك ان ترى ناقلات الجرحى التي تركوها
وهي ملطخه بالدماء في هذا القب كان ينام
الجنود الروس وفي احد الايام ارسل لنا احد
المواطنين الاوكرانيين بيانات الموقع الذي
يتمركزون فيه فصفنا المبنى ونجى من كان في
القبو اما البقيه فقد قتلوا
جنود الاوكرانيون يستغربون من كما سموها
الدعايه الروسيه بانهم انسحبوا من مدينه
خرسان طواعيه ويقولون هذا القصف والهجوم
المضاد الذي قادته القوات الاوكرانيه هو
الذي اجبر القوات الروسيه عن التخلي عن
مواقعها والانسحاب الى الضفه اليسرى لنهر
دينيبر والتخلي عن مدينه خرسانه التي تم
استعادتها من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
لقناتيه العربيه والحدثون
ومن دونالدز كي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
رائد الاغبر اهلا بك رائد اخر التطورات
الميدانيه
يشهد معارك ضاريه ومستمره لا تتوقف ابدا
القصف المتبادل ما بين القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه مستمر
حسب السلطات المحليه هنا
قتلت واعداد من الاصابات الفرديه من
المدنيين طبعا السلطات ايضا المحليه في
دانيت تقول بانها تتقدم
للسيطره على اطراف مدينتي اماريكا
وافريقيا في المحور الشمالي الغربي من
المقاطعه كما انها تشير كما اسلفت الى قتل
اعداد من المرتزقه البولنديين الذين
يقاتلون من محور خارج ضد لوجان في ذلك
المحور انطلاقا من مدينتين الايمان
تقول الدفاع الروسيه بانها صدقت هجمات
مرتده كما وصفتها في جنوب المقاطعه من
مدينه اوغلودار نحو القوات الروسيه
القريبه من النظافه هذا بخصوص لكن لابد من
الحديث ايضا عن محور الزبروجه حيث تشير
الدفاع الروسيه ايضا الا انها حيدت من
الصلاه صواريخ في مقاطعه زاباروجي طرف
الجيش الاوكراني وانها اسقطت اربعه صواريخ
كما انها اسقط الطائرات مسيره تحاول
الوصول الى منطقه تماركوس الجيش الروسي
على الضفه الشماليه من نهر دنيني برو في
الاورو بعض الروايات متناقضه
او من تقدم او من تراجع بس في نقطه مهمه
ذكرناها وانت ذكرتها في ما يتعلق بمن
وصفتهم بالمرتزقه البولنديين كيف تتعامل
روسيا مع فكره تواجهم على اساس بانهم
منظمين بمعنى اخر نحن نتحدث عن تدخل دوله
او لا زلت تتعامل معهم كمرتزقه بالفعل همم
ربما يدفع لهم او تدفع لهم من الاموال كي
يشاركوا
اشاره هامه ميسون بالفعل لو كانت روسيا
تتعامل على انهم منظمين لرفعت مستوى مستوى
التعامل في هذه الازمه العسكريه لكن هي
تتعامل وتشير الى انهم فقط مر مرتزقها
انهم يعني بالتزام فردي او
بانتساب فردي للقوات الاوكرانيه يقاتلون
كما
تنشر الى
كل الناس من دونسك نعود اليك ربما في
نشراتنا اللاحقه مراسل العربيه رائد
الاخضر شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا مشاهدينا بينما هناك نوع من الحماه
وفي المعارك الطقس يختلف كليا عن ما يدور
على الارض ولكنه يزيد من المعاناه دائره
الارصاد الجويه في كييف افادت باحتمال
تعرض العاصمه الاوكرانيه الى عاصفه ثلجيه
كثيفه بدءا من هذا اليوم ستستمر حتى منتصف
الاسبوع مع درجات حراره متوقعه تصل الى
درجه التجمد مسؤولون حذروا طبعا مسؤولون
عن عمليات توريد الطاقه حذروا بان الاوضاع
ستكون صعبه في ظل النقص الشديد في امداد
الطاقه انقطاع التيار الكهربائي تعرض
البنا التحتيه للقذف الروسي الذي طال
مناطق عده تسبب في انقطاع الماء والكهرباء
عن نحو سته ملايين شخص وفقا لتصريحات
الرئيس الاوكراني فولدمار طبعا المعاناه
لا تقتصر فقط على كيف بعد حوالي شهرين على
انسحاب القوات الروسيه من بلدتي كاميونكا
شرقي اوكرانيا يحاول سكان المدينه ايجاد
لقضاء فصل الشتاء بعد تدمر اسطح منازلهم
بالكامل جراء المعارك روايات الاهل لتتحدث
عن القاء الجنود الروسي القنابل على
منازلهمم للتسليه وايضا لقضاء الوقت دعنا
نتابع
فتحات المنازل في بلده كميانكا في ضواحي
اوزيوم لم تعد تقتصر على ابوابه ونوافذه
فسكانها يحاولون حصر الاضرار دون جدوى لا
اسقف يحتمون بها ولا ابواب تقيم شر الخارج
والاخشاب التي تهاوت عده الشتاء الذي حل
عليهم قاسيا كما القذائف خلال سيطره
القوات الروسيه عليها
البالغ عددها 55 منزلا تضررت او دمرت
تماما بسبب المعارك فيما الافتقار الى
مواد البناء ونقص العماله جعل الاصلاحات
مستبعده مع قرب انخفاض درجات الحراره الى
ما دون درجه التجمد في الايام المقبله وفي
وقت غادر معظم سكان القريه البالغ عددهم
الفا 1200 سنه يخطط الباقون للالتفاف حول
الشتاء لتكون اكوام وصناديق الذخيره التي
خلفتها القوات الروسيه المنسحبه
خيار الانسب كحطب للتدفئه وايضا كجدران
مؤقته
سوريا
انقطاع متزايد للتيار الكهربائي ترك هذه
القريه الصغيره وسكانها في عتمه بارده
الصحه في محمد البابا اهلا بك محمد نبدا
باحوال الطقس والعاصفه الثلجيه المتوقعه
كيف يتحضر لها اهل كياب
نعم بالفعل يعني صباح الخير ميسون
بدات منذ ساعات صباح الاولى درجات الحراره
في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
يعني ثلاثه تحت الصفر وهي يعني تعتبر
بارده في ظل انقطاع للتيار الكهربائي خاصه
في المنطقه التي انا موجود بها منذ مساء
الامس يعني لم تزود هذه المنطقه بالسياره
الكهربائي ومعظم المنازل يعانون من تدني
درجات الحراره لان الشبكه التدفئه يعني
مرتبطه بشبكه الكهرباء ما تقوم به يعني
الاداره المحليه في العاصمه الالكترونيه
ايجاد نقاط وتسمى نقاط الممانعه او الدفاع
او او الصمود يعني كما تترجم باللغه
العربيه وهي نقاط يتم تزويدها ب- والديدات
الطاقه الكهربائيه
ليستفئه وايضا الانترنت ايضا شبكه في
الانترنت تعاني بشكل كبير بسبب ارتفاع
تيار كهربائي عمده قياس بعد الانتقاد الذي
يعني يعني حصل عليه من الرئيس الاوكراني
القديم بالامس بعد اشرف بعض
الاشتقالات لتزويد العاصمه الاوكرانيه
قياس في التيار الكهربائي خاصه انه من
المتوقع ان تبدا العاصفه الثلجيه ثلاث
ساعات المقبله للعاصمه الالكترونيه كيف
وستعاني شبكه الطاقه لذلك بدا يعني وضع
نقاط في كل منطقه في كل حيث نقاط لدعم
السكان عبره الهواتف يعني بعض المرضى
الذين هم بيحاشدوا التيار الكهربائي
للحصول على بعض العلماء
النقاط صمود بالنسبه للطاقه الكهربائيه
ولكن قراءه في تصريحات الرئيس الاوكراني
كانت دائما ما تكون هجوميه تتحدث عن
التوحد والقوه من قبل همم الكثيرين اخر
تصريح له قارئ همم بانه لم يكن هجوم بهذه
الطريقه وكانه همم يتمنى همم قضيه التوحد
هذه في ظل الضغوطات الى اي حد هذا همم هذه
القراءه هي صحيحه وهل من تم الملك في
الشارع بالنهائي او لا زال الموقف موحد
همم بخلف
نعم لا يمكن القول ان الشعب الاوكراني
يلتفت بشكل طبيعي حول الرئيس الاوكراني في
خاصه انه قبل ثلاثه ايام على احد احدى
وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه كان هناك شبه
استفتاء حول شعبيه الرئيس الاوكراني التي
لا تزال مرتفعه وتفوق 80% من الشعب
الاوكراني الجميع يعلم الظروف التي يعني
يحكم بها في الاستخاره يعني موضوع الطاقه
الذي هذا يعتبر ضغط كبير على السكان ويعني
خاصه في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كثير يعنون
بشكل كبير ولكن هم يعلمون ان الادارات
المحليه والرئيس الاوكرانيا يفعلونه كل ما
في البيوت لتخصي هذه المرحله وايضا الرئيس
الاوكراني يعني كان كل يوم يخرج في
تسجيلات فيديو ويطلب من السكان الصمود وهي
يعني يخبرهم بكل ما يحصل بكل شفره في
الامس كان هناك اجتماع مع رئيس الوزراء
البلجيكي الذي وعد ستكون هناك مساعدات
طارئه لاوكرانيا في موضوع الطاقه عبر
التزيين اوكرا مين مولدات وبعض المعدات
البوليسيه التي تحتاجها اوكرانيا لاعاده
تصليح وترميل يعني المحطات التي تعرضت
يعني عبر الجيش الروسي خاصه في قرب بالقرب
من العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف وايضا في غرب
اوكرانيا حيث ان مدينه الجوف ومدينه ايضا
تعاني بشكل كبير في انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي المعلومات
في اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل
زعيم كوريا الشماليه يتعهد بنتلاك اقوى
قوه نوويه في العالم
بسوريا والعراق
تجمعاتنا احتجاجيه ايرانيه في اوروبا دعم
للمتظاهرين والحرس الثوري ينتشر في مدن
كرديه
المسلحين البولنديين في معركه خاركيف وكيف
تتاهب لعاصفه ثلجيه
في كاس العالم المانيا تسعى لتجنب الاقصاء
المبكر والمنتخب المغربي يتحدث الجيكا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الظهيره كشف
الزعيم كوريا الشماليه
عن هدفه النهائي لبلاده المتمثل في امتلاك
اقوى قوه نوويه في العالم وسائل اعلام
رسميه هذه تصريحات الزعيم الكوري الشمالي
جائت خلال ترقيته لعشارات من ضباط الجيش
الذين شاركوا في عمليه اطلاق اكبر صاروخ
للقارات في الاونه الاخيره
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من الدوحه العربيه
نعم نعم ميسوم ملعب الثمامه هنا ستلعب
المغرب بعد اقل من خمس ساعات من الان اربع
ساعات ونصف الساعه ستلتقي المنتخب
البلجيكي بعد ما التقت المنتخب الكرواتي
وكاله النتيجه
00 او متعادله نامل ان يفوز المنتخب
المغربي هذه المره وهناك ما بدا يتوافق
شباب من المغرب وصلوا من المحمديه تفضل
معنا اذا ممكن وصلوا قبل قليل وهم طبعا
جاءوا الى هنا من بدايه المباريات ميسول
جاءوا لي يشجعون المنتخب المغربي على امل
ان يفوز ان شاء الله بالكاس العالم كيف
حماسكم ليش وصلتوا بكير اول شيء على
الملعب يعني ملعب الثمامه حتى يفتح
الابواب بعد اقل من خمس ساعات تقريبا اربع
ساعات ونصف كيف انتم راح
اجينا بكره
على حسب الزحمه
من قال من المناطق على فكره المناطق
المناطق حتى قد تكون بعيده عن المنطقه
الساكين فيها الناس في كثير مناطق طبعا هي
في ثمان مرا همم استاذات عفوا كمان ملاعب
موزعه في في قطر او في حواري العاصمه
الدوحه وكذلك يعني يجب ان يكون هناك تنظيم
للتنقل كما يحدث منذ بدايه ال ال كاس
العالم كما شفنا امبارح طبعا مع المنتخب
السعودي وهناك شاب اخر انت برده من
المحمديه خلينا نسال الشاب اللي جاي من
تونس تفضل تخيلي ميسون يوجد يعني تلاحم
تتعاضد بين المشجعين ان كانوا عرب او من
المغرب العربي مثلا عندنا فريق المغرب راح
يلعب بس برده عندنا ويشجع تونسي وصل لتشجع
الفريق انت دائما تشجع الفرق العربيه ولا
بس اليوم عشان المغرب
اليوم يعني تنظيم عربي وممتاز وايضا
مشاركات عربيه شفنا فوز السعوديه على
الارجنتين وان شاء الله نتمنى التوفيق لكل
المنتخبات العربيه اليوم مغرب ان شاء الله
تفوز 2-0 على بلجيكا ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله نتمنى يعني هذه اجواء شكرا
لكم شكرا لكم جميعا يعني هذه الاجواء
ميسون وكمان نشاهد يعني بداوا الشباب
المغاربه نشاهد الالوان الاحمر والاخضر
همم تملا المكان مدخل المه- ال- ال-
الملعب الثمامه وكذلك اذا تحدثنا عن همم
هذا الملعب يتسع لاربعه 44,000 شخص وهناك
من وصلوا مغاربه من مناطق اخرى وصلوا من
هولندا من فرنسا من السويد
هذا كل شيء لهذه اللحظه واكيد راح يكون
معكم
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى اليمن الان حيث اعلنت الحكومه هناك ان
الدول الاطراف المتوقعه التي
لحظر الالغام وافقت على تمديد تقديم الدعم
لليمن في مجال نزع الالغام وذلك لمده خمس
سنوات مدير البرنامج الوطني للتعامل مع
الالغام امين العقيلي اوضح ان هذه
الموافقه جاءت خلال مؤتمر حظر الالغام
المنعقد في جنوب سويسرا بمشاركه الحكومه
اليمنيه نظرا لجهود الحكومه
ولايفائها بالتزاماتها تجاهها اتفاقيه حظر
الالغام
مشاهدينا الان الى لارا واخبار الظهيره
الاقتصاديه لارا تفضلها
مشاهدينا اذا اهلا وسهلا بكم همم سوق
الاسهم السعوديه تعمق من الخسائر واحد
بالمئه من التراجعات باسقط على ارتفاع
البحرين ايضا تسجل بعض المكاسب قطر تراجع
بنص نقطه مئويه اذا سوق الاسهم السعوديه
بعد تراجعات اسبوعيه ايضا تخطت الواحد
بالمئه اليوم تبدا الاسبوع على خسائر لا
ننسى لانه اسعار النفس جلال التراجعات
لثالث اسبوع على التوالي هذه بعض الشركات
التي نتبعها اليوم في السوق من ضمنكم
ارامكم عينت سيتي جروب
هذه الشركه هي شركه تابعه مملوكه بنسبه
70% لارام قوه 30% من شركه جدو تحت 30%
ولكن كل هذه الحصه المطروحه هي من نصيب
حصه جدول وبالتالي بعد الطرح سوف تبقى حصه
ارمكم بشركه لو هي عند 70% مجموعه تداول
اليوم السهم فيه بعض التراجع باربعه اشهر%
شركه تابعه لمجموعه تداول هلا شركه وامات
واقع اتفاقيه مع شركه المبادرات الثانيه
لشراء
51% من شركه شبكه مباشر الماليه تدفع 134
مليون ريال سيره السهم يسجل بعض التراجعات
هنا بواحد فاصل سبعه في المئه في اخبار
انه
تدرس همم طرح شركه تابعه هيومي للتاجير
همم تنوي تعمل لها سبنر او شكل الدماج همم
ولكن هذا الامر يخضع لموافقه الجمعيه
العموميه وبالتالي سوف تدعو الى اشتباع
الجمعيه العموميه في وقت لاحق اسهم المواد
الاساسيه سابك معادن ينساب كلها تسجل
تراجعات في جلسه اليوم سابك كانت اعلنت
مؤخرا بانها تدرس انشاء مصنع لتحويل
البتروكيماويات
ااا او لتحويل النفط الى كيماويات بشكل
مباشر
بقدره انتاج ب 400,000 برميل هي تنمو
انشاء هذا المصنع براس الخير اا السابق
للمغذيات الزراعيه ايضا على تراجع بثلاثه
بالمئه والمتقدمه كذلك تسجل خسائر اسهم
البنوك ضعيفه في جلسه اليوم كل هذه البنوك
عم بتسجل تراجعات واخيرا اسهم الاتصالات
اس تي سي الوحيده التي تسجل الارتفاعات
ضمن هذه اللائحه مشاهدينا نعود الان الى
ميسون لمتابعه نشره الاخبار
شكرا لك لارا تفجرت احتجاجات في مدينه
شنغهاي في ساعه مبكره من صباح هذا اليوم
هذه الاحتجاجات تطالب بالتراجع عن قيود
قبض ناينتين الشديده بعد ثلاث سنوات من
بدء ظهور هذه الجائحه هذه الاحتجاجات ايضا
تاتي في وقت عبر فيه العديد من سكان المدن
الصينيه عن غضبهم من حريق الاسبوع الماضي
والذي اسفر عن سقوط قتلى في اقصى غرب
البلاد
[موسيقى]
وفي ما يتعلق بقبضه نايتين شدد الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه استرا زنكا السيرفسكال
السوريات
لم ينتهي مؤكدا على ضروره التكيف مع الامر
كما يتم التعايش مع فيروسات الانفلونزا
اوضح ايضا انه معظم الاشخاص الذين يصابون
بكرونا يمرضون بشكل اساسي بضعه ايام فقط
لا يحتاجون الى تلقي العلاج في المستشفيات
تركيا تقصف ريف حلب ومطر منك العسكري
وتعلن مقتل 22 مسلحا في سوريا والعراق
تجمعات الاحتجاجيه ايرانيه في اوروبا دعما
للمتظاهرين والحرس الثوري ينتشر في مدن
كرديه
اذا المشاهدين وصلنا الى نهايه هذه النشره
اخبار الظهيره نلتقي غدا ونشره جديده
مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا